I'm Alejandro I'm an architect at Ponder
I can see that the formatting on this
slide is already a bit off
um so you'll have to again excuse me for
for the uh logistical issues here
uh this talk is meant to be an
introduction into modin which is my
team's open source project designed to
help scale pandas workflows
okay
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about modin at a high level give you
some examples of how modin is being used
in industry I'll try and get to a demo
if we have time and also do some q a so
everybody has a chance to ask uh away
yeah the formatting is not good
and if I go full screen
okay
we will just have to do this with
not the right formatting anyways
um everybody loves pandas we're at a pi
data conference so I imagine most people
on this call uh are familiar with pandas
um one fun fact that even the the pandas
aficionados uh may not know about is
that pandas has had more than two
billion downloads which is just an
astronomical number people love it
because it's so easy to use and so easy
to learn
[Music]
um
one of one of the things that we see let
me zoom out one of the things that we
see is that people frequently start to
experiment and prototype with pandas
because of those very nice features
uh but the issue is that pandas doesn't
scale
so because pandas doesn't scale as you
try and get more data and and scale up
your analysis
you end up having to refactor your code
into some other framework
um
which is not very efficient uh
once you're in a testing environment and
you you take that first step to to take
your sample data and scale it up a bit
in in a testing environment once you
want to go to prod you might have to
refactor again
uh
and even after you go to prod things
inevitably break
so you have this whole feedback loop
where the people on the right that are
in charge of doing the initial modeling
on the far left hand side doing the
initial prototyping and really
understand the domain they hand it off
to an engineering team who helps test
and deploy it at scale that team a lot
of the times we see doesn't have the
business context around
what the application or the pipeline is
supposed to do and so we have this whole
feedback loop and in practice and in
Industry sometimes we see this take this
whole cycle take as long as six months
to go from prototype to production and
back
and so if we take a step back uh and
ask why why is this happening one of the
fundamental things that we're seeing is
that there's so much fragmentation in
the data stack in in requiring users to
refactor and use all these different
Frameworks depending on where in the
cycle you are
that really affects team productivity
and that's really the the the
objective of mode in our team's open
source project
um which is designed to give you a
seamless experience from prototype to
production
and really give users a consistent and
familiar interface across environments
and at all different scales
this slide has a bunch of animations so
it is absolutely improperly formatted
but I'll walk you through uh the
highlights in the top left hand side
it's supposed to show an animation that
just says that modem is a drop in
replacement for Mo sorry for pandas so
all you have to do is replace the import
statement and we we the objective is to
give out of the box performance benefits
um in terms of run time and memory
efficiency
in terms of modem and overall adoption
we're seeing a tremendous amount of of
traction uh we passed four million
downloads pretty recently we have over a
hundred contributors and we're in use by
over a thousand organizations and I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
that just shortly
one of the things that got me very
excited about joining the team was all
of the years of r d that went into
building modin so modin came out of the
same lab as spark at UC Berkeley the
rise lab and was grounded in years of
research where our team combines state
of the art research from the database
World state of the art research from the
distributed systems world and combine
that to really lay the foundation for
data frame theory that allowed us to
build modem
we have a GitHub project it's you can
pip install mode and feel free to check
it out it's pretty easy to get started
in the wild so to give people a little
bit of an idea of how how we're seeing
mode and used at all types of companies
all over the world and across Industries
I'll highlight a couple of examples
so in banking uh a re a recent example
is a Fortune 500 Bank told us that
um yes spark did come from the same lab
I'll answer questions on the fly if I
can uh at UC Berkeley it's called The
Rise lab
um
the the project that I was mentioning
was with a Fortune 500 Bank
who uh was doing stress testing and risk
modeling and they were able to speed up
those pipelines that were originally
written in pandas they dropped in modin
and got 8X improvements in uh
performance there so that was an
exciting one in the media space we've
seen examples of companies like Spotify
using modin to speed up their
experimentation pipelines by more than
five times which is also really exciting
in the Enterprise Ai and and data
platform space uh we've worked closely
with a company called snorkel AI they're
big in the in the data labeling space uh
the next generation of snorkels platform
is actually going to use modin under the
hood to speed up all of their labeling
processes which is also really exciting
uh and then this week the the timing is
impeccable impeccable here because we we
coincide with AWS re invent and this
week they just announced that they're
gonna ship some of their new newer
versions of their services with modern
pre-packaged and out of the box
um so we're seeing we're seeing crazy
adoption and and a lot of really
interesting use cases come up uh if
you've used modin please ping me I'm
always interested in hearing more about
how how people are using our technology
yeah
what is the magic here
the purpose of this talk is to give you
a high level if you want a deeper dive
we have another session that I'll I'll
share the details on later but what
allows us to deliver those crazy
performance improvements is
the multi-threaded and parallelized
execution that we
designed so pandas as I mentioned on the
left hand side is single threaded so
even as you increase the size of your
machine
you're there's only so much you can get
out of that Hardware because pandas is
only going to use one of the available
cores in that environment
on the other hand just by changing the
import statement and I'll show a demo
later
allows you to parallelize all of the
work take full advantage of all of the
resources in the environment and that's
what allows us to deliver those speed
UPS out of the box
so now I'll give a very practical
example
um using a library that I'm sure many of
the folks on the call have experience
with which is the hugging face
Transformers Library
we were collaborating with a global fast
food chain recently that
had written some pandas pipelines and
was using hugging face
to help do some sentiment analysis uh
for Market insights and unfortunately uh
I guess what what I'm showing here is
that because the initial implementation
of that pipeline was using vanilla
pandas
they were applying
the the hugging face model serially
and because of that and because of the
way pandas manages things in memory they
were hitting a bunch of out of memory
errors and so we we collaborated with
them to
um help them test and deploy modin
and and we were able to get them 10
times faster hugging face pipelines by
just doing a a drop-in replacement of
modin uh and that's that's what I'm
hoping to show you a demo of if I can
get the screen share to work
let me let me try and one more time and
see if the screen share cooperates
can you see can you see my screen
I'm showing up Jupiter notebook
can people see my screen
somebody wants to just let me know in
the comments okay so you can see you can
see the Jupiter notebook with the Taco
Bell logo at the top
okay awesome great that worked okay
so as I said
um this is a this is an anonymous I
guess this is using this is a toy
version of the of the case study that I
just discussed for speeding up hugging
face pipelines
um we're gonna use restaurant review
data uh to compare and and decide
whether or not we should go to Taco Bell
for dinner
um Taco Bell is a popular
um Mexican fast food restaurant in in
I'm sure people are familiar with it
um some of the team some of our team
really loves it so sometimes we whenever
we get together at our company meetings
we're always debating where we should go
for dinner
so the question is Taco Bell or not Taco
Bell
um here uh I'll just walk through this
quickly since I have 10 minutes
um we're importing hugging face the
other thing I'll call out here is that
we are importing vanilla pandas as old
PD and modin.pandas as PD and so
throughout the analysis I'm going to go
through standard data ingestion
exploration
Transformations and modeling and showing
a side-by-side comparison of performance
and also show you the differences in
syntax
[Music]
which there are none by the way
so on the ingestion side I have a bunch
of I have a couple of flat files in S3
if I were to read these using pandas
vanilla pandas old pd.readcsv
I can see it takes almost four minutes
to read the two files uh into my
business and reviews data frames
if I'm reading uh with modin I can see
that the syntax is identical to pandas
and I'm still pointing at S3 and it
takes uh just under a minute and a half
so right out of the gate operation
number one I'm getting 3x speed UPS
reading from S3 without having to change
any code
understanding the data so I'm going to
talk about Transformations and modeling
so just so everybody has a sense of
what's in the data we have two data
frames that we just read in the business
table just has simple uh business
information around
location on the right hand side we can
see the type of business is it a dentist
is it a restaurant what type of
restaurant
um
in the reviews table
we have the raw text information as well
as the number of stars is it a three
star or a five star review
um overall in this sample we have just
short of four gigabytes of data and I'm
doing this on a 16 core machine uh on
AWS is where I originally did this
analysis
the thing and here for example
the point that I'm trying to make here
is that the user experience is the same
whether I am previewing a data frame up
here or whether I am doing a simple
Seabourn plot to look at the the
histogram here the user experience is
the same whether I'm using mode in or
whether I'm using pandas it looks and
feels and and and and and and every
everything is the same here
so now that we know what's in the data
let's get to really answering that
question of Taco Bell versus not Taco
Bell
um
in in I'll skip ahead a little bit so
um we're comparing reviews this is a
very high level summary stat 2.6 versus
3.8 so it seems like Taco Bell doesn't
do so well against other Mexican
restaurants
um and
The Next Step Beyond just looking at
stars is let's look at the core reviews
that what what are people actually
saying maybe maybe the number of stars
uh isn't a fair comparison because
everybody has bias in in what a star
means to them so let's try and be a
let's look at what they're actually
saying in the reviews
in order to do any uh NLP modeling like
sentiment analysis which is what we're
gonna do we always need to do
pre-processing so here I'm just showing
uh an initial pre very simple
pre-processing step where I do some
lowercase operations I do some
truncation and some other simple
manipulations to get my data into what I
call the Mexican food reviews data frame
which which just contains the the
reviews
text
if I do that in pandas it takes just
over 30 seconds here if I copy and paste
the code and I just use a mode in data
frame instead of the pandas data frame
I'm getting about two times faster
pre-processing
you'll notice that these are relatively
simple operations
um so I'm getting 2x faster
and what we see is that as the data gets
bigger and as the complexity of the
operations increases mode and delivers
increased performance benefits so the
more computational intents of the
operation and the larger the data set
the more the the benefit from using
modin hopefully that answers one of the
questions
um that I just saw pop up
okay so we have the data ready to go
we've done some pre-processing now it's
time to do the the language modeling
so uh just to walk you through what the
overall pipeline does we are using
hugging face Transformers we do we use
the Bert model to do sentiment analysis
uh and tokenization
here I Define this sentiment
classification pipeline that returns
both the sentiment and the confidence
I know I have five minutes left so I'll
speed up
um if I were to do this with my Mexican
Food review data frame
in pandas
and I apply the hugging face
classification pipeline here
unfortunately I run this thing for five
hours and the system crashes
if I again copy and paste the code and
don't do anything differently except you
use modem instead of pandas my pipeline
runs in about 20 minutes at least 12
times faster than than this kind of
funky pandas pipeline that that
sometimes works sometimes doesn't
um and that's hopefully gives you a
sense of
um modem in practice if you want to
review some of this code and and follow
along on your own
if you go to ponder.io our blog I wrote
a blog post about this and you can
follow through and and see this analysis
there
okay uh
I
have a couple more let's see
how do I get back to my slides okay
um I showed the demo
I will quickly say
um
this is the overall architecture of
modin
um I won't get into the details here but
basically
um a lot of the things that our team did
at Berkeley and has continued to evolve
at Ponder which is the company that we
have to offer the Enterprise version of
modin
is really around mapping this very
complex
over 600 operator API of pandas and
mapping that down and distributing it
across different hardware and different
execution engines
um if you're curious about that my
colleague Rehan durani is doing a talk
here at Pi data Global in a couple of
hours uh so feel free to join that and
really get get a deeper look into what
that what this uh system actually does
and what everything on here actually
means
um as for uh what we do at Ponder we are
really pushing the boundaries of
what's up what's possible with modin our
goal at Ponder is to give people the
ability to write pandas wherever they
are and on whatever scale data they're
they're dealing with
um
right now folks may may have the the
people that have already worked with uh
modin may have already tried running
mode in on their laptop or on-prem or
even in the cloud or on a cluster
um we're pushing well beyond that and
looking other at other types of
execution engines and like the database
um to give people the ability to write
pandas code directly on their database
which is some pretty pretty fun stuff
we're doing
um okay I'll jump to here
[Music]
um
any questions from from anybody
um if you're curious to my email is if
you're curious to
um get in touch with me my email is
right here Alejandro ponder.io if you're
curious to try out what we've been
building at Ponder Beyond what's just in
the open source feel free to go to this
URL
QR code might make it a little bit
easier
um
now I have two minutes for questions
let me see
uh
yeah we have quite a few questions yeah
um home mode and handles out of memory
issues that come with pandas uh good
question one of the things that people
like is
um that modin spills to disk so
typically if you're using pandas and you
run out of memory
your system crashes with modin
we then start to Spill the disc and read
and write from disk to prevent the
system from failing
um so that's that's pretty nice
do you have any well-known use of pandas
where modin is limited
um
right now one of the things that sets us
apart relative to many other data frame
systems is our unparalleled coverage of
the pandas API so we we do distribute
more than 90 percent of the pandas API
which is something that other systems
can't do
um
direct time so I'm gonna ask everyone to
maybe move to Discord where you can ask
questions directly or uh if you have
time you can jump into the YouTube chat
and answer questions there as well okay
thank you so much